good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy friday
it's friday friday gotta get down on
friday
nothing feels as good as saying that oh
my god you just gotta get it out wow
what a really long
hard torturous week i wanna say and i'm
glad to be putting it behind us
it was an okay week for me it's been a
rough one for me physically i feel like
every day of the week i woke up with a
new ailment and today i actually i'm
feeling good and i'm sort of switching
up my morning routine to include
water juliana drinking a lot of water
i'm so glad you brought that up because
i have really been into you know testing
out different seltzers and like
really finding the best and excuse me
there's hair in my seltzer
um i am now into lemon look lacroix
lacroix not lacroix christian lacroix
it's
however you want to say it i think well
i heard it's made it was common and i
think how you say it says a lot about
you
yeah so tread lightly yeah it's made in
wisconsin it's lacroix like one thousand
right
but i might just be annoying and be la
croix and this is very good i actually
for a while had a lot of you know
hesitation about drinking seltzer in a
can
but i tried the lemon bubbly and that
was excellent so i'm just on this
journey you know
very very nice yeah i just i'm starting
to drink water before my two coffees so
like now i'm on the coffee grind but
like i had water
as i did my makeup and like i do feel
like it's better for
everything about my life to have some
water seltzer's water right
so i think your body like categorizes it
as water
but there's nothing like good old water
juliana i
actually couldn't agree last like
water's disgusting and i will do
everything in my power
to get my daily water without actually
just drinking like a glass of water like
i will literally get a bottle of water a
glass and put crystal light in it like i
will get seltzer i just won't
no those things are good and i think
throughout the day they're good but like
you should drink
i believe some straight up water see i
just
i can't do but my body was starting to
break down they were saying like
you must drink some water so i'm
switching things up
hopefully it goes well because the way
that i felt this week like never again i
can't
i can never i can't do that we have an
amazing show for you guys today
mostly because taylor swift's new album
is out and i have done the work
um as much as i could do in you know the
short period of time and i'm just like
feeling overwhelmed by everyone like
already putting out their rankings like
chill these things take time
i'm going to talk about some of my
feelings the music video we have a
southern charm recap
um and just the there's a lot of things
to discuss to round out the week and i
feel like there's just been a lot going
on this week it's been a hilarious week
to be a toaster really like yeah there's
been
so much funny stuff so many ijs so many
ijs
oh and you know this is bittersweet
next week is our last week of shows
before our winter break that
next week are the last shows of 2020.
you guys
thank the lord i i'm so excited
thank you behind us but as we leave you
you know into the new year
i just think it's really important that
we all set our expectations like when we
wake up on january 1st like
things are not going to be better you
know but like i think that everyone is
committed that once that calendar year
changed just like you know
january you have your resolutions you're
going to the gym like i think everyone
is committed to like
trying to make things better in the new
year but i just think some of us like
the lazier people like me like we're
thinking we're gonna wake up and like
concert you know there's going to be
something every day and it's not it's
still going to be like
20 20 vibes in terms of what's actually
going on in the world so just
level your expectations it's a new leaf
at one point during this year like it
became clear that 2020 was awash
you know i think it was like april and
it's like things aren't happening until
2021 so no not everything's gonna change
overnight but there is some
optimism that comes with 2021 there's
vaccines that are getting approved
and i just it'll be hopefully a
different vibe and i just
i look forward to putting this year in
the past so do i and all the weight i've
gained and all the misery just
bye don't know you don't know you
goodbye
good day sir oh and i'm actually having
deja vu because
last year i was like so excited for the
new year and then it became january and
i was like oh my god like i'm
filming my special and recording the
beacon this month and like it all just
happened like so fast and i wasn't ready
and now i'm in a similar position
because like it seems like my book is
like really far away
but actually come the new year like it's
right around the corner yeah
no i saw tyler cameron not to bring up
like another first-time author
but he announced yeah he looks like such
a cutie on the cover
coming out in july and i'm like that's a
long time away yeah like yours
around the corner compared to his well
now we're in a six week countdown and
i've started a little series on my
instagram stories if you haven't checked
it out
revealing something about the book every
week until the book comes out and
yesterday i revealed the chapters
i saw and i'm thinking you know i don't
know maybe i'll take suggestions for
what to reveal
if you know me it's like i'm so excited
and i have such a hard time holding it
and she's gonna read the whole book no i
have such a hard time holding anything
and i'm like look at this joke i wrote
on page 45 like
i'm so what's the word it's like
impatient
yeah you're just excited too so
like i have to tread really lightly in
my reveals because like i might actually
give away the whole bunch you know what
some of the other reveals are gonna be
or you're
you're figuring out as you go i'm gonna
do um a dramatic reading of all the
blurbs on the back
okay i am going to do like a
an excerpt okay that's what i was going
to suggest but like
not like a crazy one you know i'm like i
want to go to the best page and read the
best excerpts but no i'm going to read
like a little extra
something telling yeah and then maybe
like a little q a i don't know i haven't
decided yet but i think i'm definitely
going to do the reveal of the back next
week
okay that's that's all well and good
yeah have you oh i guess it shows on
goodreads how many pages it is
yes but there's some logistical
questions like how many pages is there a
photo insert
and you know you might have to tune into
my instagram stories to find out is
there a photo inserted yes
am i in any photos yes there's a
fabulous photo of us from camp
young um i would say like toast or
campaign you know camp camp
camp here's fat camp because there's a
lot in the book about fat camp you can
learn all more about
my book at girlwithnojob.com book if
you're in the u.s or canada all the
links are there
and if you're in another country i would
just suggest using your amazon
and searching girl with no job book but
um that's as much as i can help you i
don't think we have like a ton of
international
i don't know i work so global like it's
crazy no i mean we're in canada like
we're globalizing actually when we got
those spotify
insights for yes they give you like for
podcasters they give you the back end of
like growth and information
and okay we grew a lot in the united
kingdom this year i just want to say so
to our british toasters
good day sir is ireland in the united
kingdom
it's part of the kingdom yeah it's part
of the kingdom vibes
yes it's part of the kingdom this is our
kingdom it is
very confusing okay thank you like wales
is part of the united kingdom
and wales just gives me irish vibes yes
yeah yeah i don't know yet no okay
or scotland scotland because the queen
is always staying in scotland
yeah yeah scotland is and they're police
versus scotland yards
england scotland wales and northern
ireland
northern ireland are all part of the
united kingdom yes is what you could see
how that would be confusing
for us yeah but i guess like in order to
be the united kingdom it has to be a
united of kingdoms but they're saying
southern ireland when it isn't
oh how fast or eastern no i've got to
get to ireland you know i'm supposed to
go to ireland
i would love to see the northern lights
that's not ireland i was supposed to
greenland
it's in one of the finland no it's
reykjavik iceland
it's in the land but yes i was supposed
to go to scotland this year for a
wedding and i'm gonna say ireland and
iceland are one letter off
just one letter yes but pronunciation
wise like they couldn't be more
different i'm visualizing them so that's
how i got confused i've been trying to
tell you for like an hour that i was
supposed to go to ireland this year
to go to a wedding but alas that was
so funny i once got an email to go on
like an influencer trip to reykjavik i
think
shut up and it was like so like it
wasn't
i don't think it was like a legitimate
influencing trip um but i was tempted
because i was like i really actually
want to go there the thing is though
that like
and tpg taught me this because he's seen
that the northern lights you know like a
hundred times um
you can actually go all the way to the
journey in the northern lights like not
come out so imagine if you went on that
like treacherous trip with like a bunch
of influencers
and the lights like didn't even show up
that night yeah and i did hear that like
certain nights in alaska you can see the
northern lights so like
i think i would try that first just
regular sound so far yeah
we'll try alaska first and i feel like
alaska is good vibes
for sure i've seen the proposal it looks
amazing yes
i have not seen the epic the movie ryan
reynolds and sandra bullock you're
missing out
no no i was in the movie theater um i
just like don't remember like
nothing from the movie theater like went
into my brain stuck with you betty white
no like i know they danced around the
fire like i know the the like
the basics but i've seen the movie and i
could not tell you one thing that it's
about
okay well it takes place in alaska quite
beautiful i think that's like the only
popular movie that's ever taken place in
alaska
what about looking for alaska is that a
tv show yeah and i don't think it takes
her name is alaska yeah yep so um
semantics so i feel like we've you know
circled the drain i just want to talk
about evermore
um oh fine fine
we'll be talking about evermore
forevermore
but without further ado and before we
talk about evermore forevermore here are
the fastest stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and very appropriately since we will be
talking about music you need to drink
wine with
today's episode is brought to you by
usual wines wines for the modern drinker
where each bottle is 6.3 ounces which is
a heavy pour or about a glass and a half
of wine
so there's no more pouring wine down the
sink when you don't finish the bottle
because of the single serve format and
the bottle design usual wines are always
fresh
so you'll have no more flat bubbly or
stale rose the wines are low carb and
have zero grams of sugar
they have a red blend a rose and a
sparkling white wine called brut
they also have a limited production
brute rose just for the summer
usual wines are made from world-class
american viticultural
areas in california like napa sonoma
santa barbara so places that kardashians
go
is where the usual wines are made and
that's pretty much like all you need to
know about their quality like their
a plus um so the concept of just having
wine glasses
bottles of wine that are 6.3 ounces is
so smart because sometimes i just feel
like it's so wasteful to open a bottle
of wine if you're by yourself and like
you're not going to drink the whole
thing
um and so now is a great time to try
usual wines because they have a special
holiday product
called the usual reserve it's ultra
premium limited edition
mount vedir cabernet sauvignon usual
reserve is their most special wine yet
just in time for the holidays
hailing from one of the most celebrated
plots of land in all of napa
this cabernet sauvignon is concentrated
and rich with just enough grip
gift it to someone special or keep it
all to yourself this holiday season
go check out the website at
usualwines.com and use our discount code
toast for eight dollars off your first
order
and try your first glass on us the
website is www.usualwines.com
our discount code is toast for eight
dollars off your first order to try your
first glass
on us love it okay first story evermore
is here taylor swift's
ninth studio album dropped last night
along with this
her single and accompanying music video
for willow
so i'm seeing like everyone like posting
like rankings like
this is and it's just what's the rush
these are true like works of art they
need to be unpacked
and you know it's like i have this thing
i don't know if it's anyone else like
when i
hear a brand new song for the first time
it literally goes in my brain like
in one ear out there like gibberish like
i'm like is this even english like it
just it doesn't make
it doesn't register so i need time with
it and i'm not gonna like people are
just so hasty but of course
there are songs that automatically stand
out and if anyone cares here are mine
long story short has a nice
beat next up i think might be my
favorite is ivy
because the chorus has a choir and it's
like when you have a choir you're
automatically just
better better than everyone else um no
body no crime
so that is the hand i know what it is i
listen to the album okay
i um i was just in the middle of
evermore when i had to turn it off to
leave
but the hame one like was good because i
was liking the folksy beep but like to
me
it was just a rip-off of all his money
could never save jenny from the devil
living
in his eye it was the same song so
that's that carry underneath nobody know
crime is so good and i can't believe
that it's a hame collab
but um it was made better by the fact
that i didn't even hear hame on it like
for one second they don't actually have
their own hair
in the beginning i think they're like
like um
yeah or something like they're not it's
not like bony bear like he gets his own
verse and bridge like they're just
really like background singers
um and i love the song it gives me
before he cheats vibes it gives me
martha divine
vibes like i'm gonna kill my daddy's
lover like that whole vibe
and i just i loved it i loved it i think
that
it's a very it's it's country obviously
it's like the
the the songwriting element but it gives
me more like um
i don't know like uh i don't know what
the right genre word i'm looking for is
but it's like
maybe it's like 70s country it's not
like pop country i just loved it and
there's a harmonica in it
and whenever taylor puts a harmonica in
a song like it's automatically fabulous
a la betty so i like that one a lot i
like it's just it's church bells
it is um it's jenny it's typically
talking back to her
well it's not the story of jenny it's
the story of no no this song
you're not hearing what i'm saying no i
know what you're saying you're trying to
say taylor swift copying and i'm just
saying she didn't
but it's not a cop like it doesn't
necessarily mean copy people are
inspired just like she said how she was
inspired by
literally american all-american girl
when she was like talking about how she
likes in country music
yeah did she name all americans no but
she's talk like that's the song
so i i appreciate when people like take
inspiration from other things
but it just reminded me too much of
jenny um and then the final one that i
really liked was willow which was the
i believe the lead single the one she
released a m
music video for and i really liked the
music video it definitely gave me
valttori twilight vibes
um and i liked you know all the
metaphors you know that
one single thread of gold tied media
when she's following the single thread
of gold the entire time
it was really quite beautifully done and
i really do feel like the first album
and the second album folklore and
evermore are definitely
linked and once i have more time to like
learn and study and read
the lyrics like we'll be able to find
some more connections but they
definitely feel like one whole album
well also the music video is like a
sequel to the cardigan music videos
but i'm talking about just like the
album in general in terms of like
vibe rhythm lyrics
messaging i definitely feel like this
was
really meant to be like one whole album
you know yeah but also just the notion
that she's telling stories that aren't
her own like yeah which is what she
talked about
and i guess if she hadn't put out that
disney plus thing we wouldn't it would
be harder to decipher ever more but now
just
seeing it all through that vein of like
she's really enjoying like not
just writing her autobiographical songs
um
so i think it's it's pretty cool and i
think that's why she named
the original album folklore because
that's just like passing down stories
not necessarily your own
yeah and yeah so there's a song on um
on evermore i like never remember the
name of the album evermore
about her grandma which is really really
sweet and
we learned from the disney plus special
that there was a song about her
grandfather on the previous album so
it's just really it's spectacularly done
i really i haven't listened yet
those are some of my you know standouts
but it's important to keep in mind when
i first listened to folklore
i didn't i think i skipped piece i was
like i don't get this song these are
pieces of art they require time
don't rush to get like your instagram
story you know screenshot of your notes
like ranking up sounds like you're
talking to the snitch
no oh well you really want to know who
i'm talking about yeah
so i follow i thought like this is no
shade at all but like i just couldn't
believe how fast he got it up
i follow feidelberg from barstool he's
like the biggest taylor swift fan and he
does like such funny content
and this morning i woke up and he needed
a screenshot of his notes giving like a
score i'm like
frederberg how how and he gave nobody no
crime like a b-minus like are you
serious
so well he just doesn't listen to it the
only way you could have your ranking out
is if you haven't slept since the album
came out and you've just been listening
to it done repeat since then
i guess but like even then you have to
sit with them you have to listen to it
on a train
in your home like you have to experience
it outside
inside like i just i i think like
rankings that come out
literally less than 24 hours is insane i
think you
everyone gets at least a week yeah also
you have to like
realize which songs get stuck in your
head and you're humming to yourself and
then like they just become a part of
your daily life
you need time yes so i just i'm curious
oh i like what you did there i just want
to stress enough like there was
absolutely no shade like big federal
bird girl over here
i just couldn't believe i'm feeling
overwhelmed i feel like you're just
feeling overwhelmed
i'm so overwhelmed and i feel like
there's there is like this
culture within the swifties of like you
know who's gonna be the swiftiest and
who's gonna like
who's gonna get their rankings up first
and who's gonna set the tone for what's
the best song on the album i think
against me
and what the swifties are going to like
really are gonna be like the favorite
swifty songs you know and like i'm just
on my own journey
right and i just no shade to anyone like
everyone do what you feel is right
you can't be comparing yourself to other
people i know i'm just overwhelmed
i understand but it's such a good album
like really
thank you taylor for giving us this
experience we're just we're so
you know what i could have been born you
know anytime but i was born in the same
lifetime as taylor swift and i just
think like
there's a reason i do okay that's
beautiful
thanks um okay ready for our next story
we actually have some great stories
today and this is just a beautiful story
a beautiful love story unfolding before
our eyes
morgan stewart sport morgan stewart
sport
sounds like she's like a hyphenated name
morgan stewart sport yes
morgan stewart sport mcgraw has married
jordan mcgraw
um at home she posted a photo of their
ceremony against the jeff
lethem design flower wall she said i do
to jordan in a white chanel gown
while she's like i was in a car or
something when i got this information
and i just might the first thought that
popped into my head is like damn i've
done nothing with my ear like gained
weight
been an animal like you know found
myself in some trouble and like morgan
stewart's just over here like doing the
most you know like
making a life for herself and i'm so
happy for her
she's building a life for herself this
year yeah and you know it's like i kind
of love
this trend of like small weddings and
even though like
it looked so sickening i'm sure the
budget was outrageous because i had this
like little dinner with the family
afterwards
and like that flower wall by jeff lethal
couldn't have cost less than 20 thousand
dollars
but like i don't know i kind of love
this this like trend of like
understated like simple all about the
love weddings yeah
no so do i it's like for other people
like for me i liked my big wedding no
but it's like everyone
is choosing love over all the glitz and
the glam and i think it's a really nice
trend
i agree and especially and i feel like
before corona like we were all so caught
up like that
material items like yada yada and now
it's like we're just back to like the
simple things and the things that matter
and we'll get into it but that's how i
really felt about austin and
madison like madison learning over like
quarantine like
this is fun but like this is not what i
need for my long-term life you know
yeah and it's like we're all just
learning these lessons about like what's
important
and i just love this i absolutely love
this
i really didn't expect this to i hadn't
really thought about it
but i didn't expect it and so i just
some unexpected love unfolding before
our eyes we absolutely love to see it
like jordan mcgraw is like so lucky like
he gets to hang out with morgan stewart
and just like laugh
and like listen to her opinions and like
laugh and like be entertained
and like that's how our husbands must
feel about us yeah for sure
definitely i actually i i was you know
our husbands were hanging out and i
actually overheard your husband say that
to my husband and like my husband was
like
you're so right such a gift to live with
jackie not only
is she so hilarious yeah and opinionated
and smart and outspoken but she also
gives amazing advice it's true yeah he
did say that and
and then ben to which ben responded yeah
no i feel the exact same way living with
claudia is the best because like one
she makes such a nice home and she like
thinks of all the things that i would
never think of like re-buying paper
towels and
i just come home every day without
blinking like i live in a nice place
with nice things and nice furniture
in a well-maintained home and i really
appreciate that on top of you know her
being the coolest funniest you know most
amazing smart genius girl i've ever met
and i didn't want him to you know know
that i overheard but i did and you know
zach's phone he was accidentally
facetiming me and i heard
ben say and to live with uh such a
comedian yeah like
i'm always laughing and that's so funny
because to which zach responded
um no i know exactly what you mean like
you know jackie maybe doesn't get as
much credit for it's claudette's
claudia's so annoying but
jackie's like so funny and ben was like
no i totally agree like
we're so lucky that's that's just how i
heard the conversation then
i might have missed her don't quote me
and then they were also just saying like
and how
fortunate are bruno and theo to have
moms like claudia and jackie and
yes that was really nice and then that
prompted ben to say
um yeah and it's like when claudia
wanted to get a dog like i didn't even
want to get a dog your husband
yeah yeah and claudia like forced me to
get this dog and like now i pretend like
it was all my idea and like theo likes
me better when i know like for sure like
bruno i mean theo definitely likes
claudia better as she should because if
i was theo i would like claudia better
because she's a genius and she's
beautiful
stunning and smart and to which sack
said
ditto yeah but don't quote me i'm just
paraphrasing
yeah so anyways we can understand how
jordan mcgraw might be feeling right now
no but he's just the luckiest man in the
world that literally like spiraled off
so hard but what i meant to say is like
i just feel like morgan stewart's like
so interesting and i feel like she
doesn't open up to a lot of people do
you know what i mean
so to be hidden at her her most trusted
company to be like the guy she opens up
to
and then also like get to father child
with her like
some people are just born lucky
truly oh my god i'm really happy for her
and she looked really pretty like yeah
she's just so elegant
so elegant and i also feel like we all
saw her wedding
her first wedding that was like you know
the wedding and it was televised
and it couldn't have been bigger and
more beautiful and she had all of those
things and it's like at the end of the
day
you realize those things don't matter
because that is not a happy marriage
make right
so i just think this is a wonderful
display of love
i agree true love true
love what's that um
i don't know but it's like a song it's
like you're a true
friend it's giving me that vibe
i don't even know what song i was
thinking maybe it's an original
it's a jumping off point it is okay
do you know what i'm singing
it said david archuleta and hannah
montana song
i don't know i think that's the song
what's the david remember and david
archuleta
it was um it wasn't funny how the word
cameo has like
changed so much over time yeah because
if i said david archuleta did a cameo
you would think he sent a video to your
friend for her birthday
oh he did i want to know you whoa
can't remember anyone's name remembers
every hannah montana lyrics since
seventh grade
when i saw you over there i didn't mean
to stare but my mind was everywhere i
wanna know you
i could guess the joe the kind to see
what's on your mind and with some when i
have something to show
you you smile in a crowd you stand out
in the crowd
you make the best of every situation
correct me if i'm wrong i'm present and
you're strong and here for the perfect
combination
[Music]
i left you hanging for one second i
wanna go
there where you go i wanna find out what
you know maybe someday down the road
i'll sit
back and say to myself that i thought so
so that obviously wasn't what i was
saying
that wasn't the true love song i was
thinking but i'm glad we had that moment
i just do want to find
there is a hannah song that starts with
true true
love i don't know what song i'm trying
to think of right now i'm thinking it's
maybe
true friend yeah of course
[Laughter]
to pretend you're a true
friend okay still not the song i was
singing but it's okay
okay should i just search true love i
don't know if it's hannah montana
there's a song with pink and lily allen
there's ariana grande there's dove
cameron
jordan fisher did a ballad version then
dove and jordan
so you know what anyone listening to the
podcast if you know what song this is
just like hit me up
true love i don't even know what i'm
singing anymore like
no it's just an original okay true love
audio that's the worst thing to happen
by claudia ashrae that's like naming
your band claudia ashrae i'm
so i was so shook up by yesterday's
episode and i got a lot of feedback from
the rascal flat situation i just think
i want to say two things one um i think
a lot of people thought that
in the episode yesterday i was finding
out for the first time that the band
rascal flats is named for the band not
the person and
no that i already knew that my shock and
i think i found the source of the shock
was that my whole life since since
finding out that rascal flatts
was the name of the band not the guy i
just always thought the name rascal was
a name like a common name
and now i'm realizing i was probably
confusing it with randall or pascal
no i don't think so
okay are you ready for our next story
it's something you're
really interested in the kardashians
will be going to
hulu in 2021 okay this is weird like i
first of all we totally predicted that
they were going to a streaming service i
just didn't think it was going to be
hulu yeah i think because hulu's like no
offense kind of loser
could not agree more was until the
kardashians and by the way by the time
they have the kardashians on they need
to figure out their playback situation
yeah
you hanging in the middle of an episode
yes ma'am get your user navigability
up i do i think that due to the current
state of loseriness of hulu
they want they had the most to gain from
getting the kardashians and so they
ponied up to the bar
any streaming service would be lucky to
have the kardashians it was a money
thing
whoever gave them the most money is
where they were going and hulu obviously
gave them the most money
yeah and hulu is a part of disney so
they had to see
the money to spend and this was um
announced during disney's investor day
on thursday no i mean it's great for us
we're getting more kardashian content
unfortunately i like i will have to
spend more time on hulu
um in the future which is just upsetting
because as we talk about all the time
here it's just not
and you watch on apple tv yeah give me
two it's just i don't know what it's
like on other
like google chrome or roku but it is
just not a user friendly experience like
by any means
yeah and i just want to i want to um
explain the issue that i'm having in
case anyone works for hulu tech
so i'll be watching a show the bowl type
and i'm saying
i'm in season i'm on episode five
and i leave get a snack whatever my hulu
exits out fine because i
took a long time maybe it was a meal and
i come back and i'm like resume watching
and i'm at season
i'm on episode four at the beginning
yeah i'm not where i was
yeah they don't have a good memory i
agree there's just something off about
like if
you should be able to like pause your tv
temporarily on hulu without having to
like literally take 10 minutes to get
back to where you are
and more often than not it's just so um
all over the place for me on hulu so
they're gonna need to figure that out
like asap
but really happy that kardashian's
legacy will live on in tv now in the
streaming wars and the streaming wars
just got even more interesting i mean
every week it's another thing you know
competition benefits the consumer and
here we are just consuming it all
and it honestly i was saying before like
i could have been born in any time
and i'm so glad to be alive in the same
time as taylor swift and the streaming
wars like and the kardashians
yeah yes and the streaming wars i would
love to know
what the paycheck was but that
information was not disclosed but maybe
it will be one
i mean we can guess if you think about
it like what's their value
streaming services pay they overpay so
like
matthew no not matthew adam sandler got
300 million dollars to do like what like
six movies for netflix
ryan murphy and like his whole crew they
got also like 300 million dollars
to do a bunch of tv shows so i think the
kardashians are worth
at least that yeah i agree i wonder how
many seasons they're going to plan to do
i'm just saying what like are they all
getting their own show no i feel like
it's just going to be
keeping up under a different name unless
they own the name which they probably
don't
and they're going to keep doing what
they're doing maybe
there'll be changes like first of all i
think maybe they'll have like bigger
budgets
yeah and maybe there'll be no
commercials like maybe the length
maybe the format might be different yeah
so i think it's wonderful it'll be
titled it's definitely not going to be
able to be keeping up it might just be
the kardashians because that's what
people call it anyway oh that's true
um also now this leaves uh
a lot up in the air as it pertains to e
because
for like the last like five years he has
just been like a network that can't get
it right in terms of programming
but they always had kardashians on and
that was always the backbone even the
kardashians spin-offs like that always
made e
like a respectable network but now
they're no more lady gang no more busy
phillips like no more kardashians
every like it's so nice of you to
include busy phillips in there
i wasn't including in that wasn't a list
of like good ones i was just saying like
programming that's been
like like let go recently but lady gang
was excellent they should have kept lady
gang
um yeah so busy now the bradshaw bunch
i'm sure that'll get canceled any minute
now
so now it's like the wwe channel yeah
because it's like all the different
spin-offs of total divas
yeah and then like daily pop nightly pop
yeah and by the way
jelly pop is the crown jewel of and
nilly pop they're the crown jewels of a
like
but now without the kardashians like
they're really going to need to step it
up
some more family reality shows and like
they're just trying such weird things
like this kevin
kevin hart's subway game night what is
that i don't know i haven't tuned in
like
zoom tv have you watched the bradshaw
bunch no but i actually feel like i
would like it i feel like it's probably
good
oh also i don't know if it's a story but
you see ellen has corona i
i saw and it's not a story yeah she's
just not having a good year i mean
nobody is but ellen specifically but at
least she's having a bad year like from
her mansion
totally um in more streaming wars news
because disney was just like
dropping so many left and right
announcements yesterday
amy adams is set to start an enchanted
sequel
called disenchanted for disney plus cute
i mean
she that movie that's now on disney plus
with her and jillian bell what's it
called
it's not her it's isla fisher and it's
called godmother but it is so similar
and that is just what i was going to say
but it's similar just like nobody no
crime and and
church bells like they're similar and i
like them both and they're inspired like
it's inspired but yes because eileen
fisher and amy adams look so similar
and now isla fisher's in a role that's
like so enchanted i just assumed it was
amy adams yeah
no it's literally that movie is
enchanted 2020 version and i guess we're
getting disenchanted
next year which i'm excited about that
movie enchanted was so [ __ ] good i
hope james marsden is still in it
it was such a great concept and the
music like slapped
i just have to say if there's a recipe
for like a decent movie
you know there's budget whatever all
these little recipes
as long as you have a pinch of james
marsden your movie's a hit
a hundred percent he made that hairspray
reboot or not right now
he left it all at the corner show
courtney left it all on the dance floor
and it was
it's inspiring as you know uh a phil
a thespian myself it's inspiring and he
really just did the most on that movie
yeah no he he's really great always he
was great and dead to me he's just like
an amazing actor who i feel like
doesn't get as much work as he should
you know what i mean i i completely
agree
so handsome too so handsome and sings
and dances he does
most he does does the most also i didn't
even realize this but
enchanted had it earned three oscar
nominations in the best original song
category oh
happy working song so close and that's
how you know
oh my god i'm so embarrassed i have
something to say you've never seen it
i've never seen enchanted
oh my god treat yourself this weekend i
will i'm sorry
alan minkin worked on the soundtrack so
you know it's good yeah
um wow i might watch it also
there's where she like leaves the
fairyland and london new york yes and
also there is a song that carrie
underwood sings
ever ever i actually know that song
oh my god the soundtrack is so good i'm
going to treat myself this weekend okay
to watching enchanted
and oh then god i'm having a stroke
i kind of have a busy weekend do you no
i think theo would love enchanted i
think he would too you know he loves a
musical
he does you know bruno still hasn't seen
greatest showman wow
he's missing out he is missing out is it
time for the fifth and final
it's time for the fifth and final story
but is it the fifth and final story
brought to you by alka glam
yes do you find yourself going through
facial mists and not seeing a difference
in your skin
is your skin feeling dry midday yes all
the time are constantly buying facial
mists to set up your makeup and refresh
your skin and the cost of repurchasing
throughout the year adding up
yes i mean i have i love the idea of a
facial mist
but either they're so crazy expensive or
they literally do nothing and they have
like
really toxic like chemicals in them it's
really hard to find a good balance
until alka-glam they convert your
distilled water into a mineral facial
mist within 20 seconds
packed with magnesium zinc tourmaline
and vitamin c it gives you an instant
radiance and supple skin within 20
seconds
it can be it can also be refilled for an
entire year so what does alka glam do
their technology is clinically tested to
reduce redness accelerate wrinkling
excessive dryness and enlarged pores and
bring out colors in makeup
it's super easy to use just fill up the
alka glam with distilled water and shake
and you activate all the ingredient
tablets that release into the water
for the entire year once the water is
depleted just refill it again with
distilled water
it's so easy to use i used it and it was
like crazy genius like i i couldn't
believe that this is the first type of
thing on the market
um and it's fabulous and i love the idea
of a facial mist but just sometimes
the ones that i've tried are just
unfortunately nothing of the sort but
thanks to alkalam you have a facial mist
that's everything of the sort alkaline
became the winner of this year's big
find on hsn and sold out over seven
times on air
check out the fantastic reviews on
hsn.com and use the promo code toast
for 15 off your order on alkaglam.com
and it ships just in time for christmas
that's a l k a g
l a m dot com promo code toast for 15
off give the gift of radiant skin with a
revolutionary product that lasts
all year long use promo code toast for
15
off your order love it okay fifth and
final story
jenny slate is pregnant she is expecting
her first baby with her fiance
who is an artiste okay i'm having um
i know every time we talk about gender i
know it goes down this role
so jenny slate is the wife from polka
king yes
amongst other things but that's what i
remember her from and she
briefly dated captain america yes okay
and captain america wait let me just
i'm two for two let me try three captain
america's name
is chris evans yes we're learning it
only took us
three years and we're getting so good so
she's pregnant she's pregnant she
announced it on um
late night with seth meyers late night
with one of the jimmies
yeah late night at night and um she's
engaged too
so just very exciting and exciting news
everyone's been getting it on in
quarantine and now we're seeing the
fruits of our labor literally
literally you shall bear fruit i love a
little
bit bad news it's different like in 2020
you know
yeah and you know speaking of bad bad
news there were a lot of babies running
around last night's episode of southern
charm
there were pringles babies oh the kids
babies the kids they were they're not
babes
no they're children they're campers
they're campers yeah um all right so tv
recap southern charm was on last night
and i caught up on last week's episode
too
and i have to say it was a fabulous
episode for many reasons one because
there was like really a vulnerable
moment between austin and madison like
that was real as [ __ ] like
that was not stage like and that was
really crazy and then two i feel like
every um pretty much every show that was
filmed this year
is covering coronavirus and the black
lives matter movement
and i found both of those particularly
interesting in southern
charm specifically because charleston is
like this old southern town
and it i guess what was going on in
charleston was so different coveted wise
than what was going on here yeah because
everything seems so much more relaxed
and it's like for us
it was so crazy so fast but then you
forget like that was
a few places but not everywhere like in
march where literally no one could leave
your house
yeah no a lot of cities and i think they
had said this two weeks ago
in southern charm like some cities
hadn't really been hit yet by covid when
they shut down so they didn't understand
as much like what the enormity of it i
feel and you can feel that sort of
energy from some of the cast members
and yeah it did affect how they were
able to open up and whatnot so it is
interesting to see
how people in different cities like
experienced shutdowns and it's
completely polar opposite from what we
were dealing with here it looked
fabulous like they were at the beach
yeah no and it also even oc i felt like
was more well i guess because california
was more similar to new york
yes but it it is interesting how like so
i think it's real houses of atlanta real
houses of orange county and southern
charm are all
sort of like filming from june right now
and we're all in the same time period
but seeing how everyone is handling it
differently and and i really am finding
it interesting
yeah and then as it pertains to the
black lives matter movement i thought it
was really interesting to see what was
going on in southern charm
one because charleston is it's like old
southern town and two
you know these um people on the show
like do have
roots in like american john calhoun
essentially
so i thought that the part about taking
down the statue i just thought that was
fascinating and i thought bravo had like
amazing footage of like this
historic moment and it actually like had
chills at one point and i thought it was
like really well done and like
just like the conversations being had
around it and like lev and her group of
friends and danny like
because i just caught up on two weeks
ago as well i thought it was like
really like a very like interesting and
also educational
it's very educational i it inspired me
to like learn more about
john calhoun a lot of stuff that i
didn't know and i was i just know him as
like one of the guys on the declaration
of independence yes
and i was reading about his legacy and
it said
i was as i was watching the episode
which hadn't which was i watched it like
30 minutes late and it said
the removal of his statue was featured
on episode five of season seven
wikipedia so like southern charm is
really like a part of history now
i thought it was in the wikipedia yeah i
thought it was so cool and i really
enjoyed it
and you know what i feel like as it
pertains to catherine
she was like in this situation where she
claims she didn't use this emoji to
you know be racist and i just feel like
she's acting like it's really not a big
deal when it is especially if you
remember like the climate in june like
things were just so different than they
are now
and i feel like she was under so much
fire like she got fired from
gwynns is that what it's called um i
feel like she really should have used
that opportunity to speak out like she's
probably the most well-known descendant
of john calhoun right
yeah and for a while she went by
catherine calhoun dennis she doesn't go
by that really anymore she's catherine
dennis now
so i feel like she it was could have
been like a really cool opportunity for
her to like speak out about it because
her
voice carries weight in charleston
especially as it pertains to john
calhoun but she's just like messy like i
don't know
what's going on with her i don't know
what's going on with her and then like
the whole thing about how this has like
become a fight between her and danny i
wasn't totally understanding
me neither because she had that face
time with leva and i thought leva
um did like i'm sure levi did not want
to speak to her like after
all this drama but i thought level was
like really mature with her and like
very straightforward and like
not confrontational but just direct but
then level like went into that
directness about danny and it's like
why are we equating like the danny
situation with the emoji situation like
we're acting like they're one thing and
they're not right danny's man
by the way danny has ground to stand on
like catherine is honestly
not a good friend and danny is not only
a good friend but she's like above and
beyond for years like when they were
going back to all those clips
she's oh and so cap danny is 100
validated in feeling like
you're going through something like
you're not even going to reach out to me
and like i reached out to you like i
totally get it
but i just feel like they're acting like
these two things are like the reason
they're equal reasons as to why we're
mad at catherine when it's like no one
is up here and like one's down here yes
you know
yes i agree and but i didn't understand
what level was saying it's like you
can't control what other other people
think about you people that you don't
know but like
what you can work on is like the people
who know you and love you and
you're not even like tending to those
relationships so i understood like
where she was coming from but like get
the transition yeah
but i agree with you that it didn't feel
like
these two things are equal equal as to
why
everyone is like upset with catherine
even chef two was like being like
making it about danny when it's like
this isn't about danny it's almost like
some people are like trying to skirt
around the conversation around
catherine and like what she meant by
that emoji yeah
um also i read a tweet last night that i
thought was like a fabulous idea because
honestly like
so many people are spending time at
their homes and levi's house is
literally nicer than everyone else's
house combined like she's
she's so successful we need a vanderpump
rules at republic like isn't that a good
idea
yes that's an amazing idea amazing idea
i can't take credit for it like i saw
someone tweeted because i love to read
tweets about like
the bravo shows because i never know
like if i'm feeling like alone or like
if how i'm feeling is unique you know
yes so that was just a great idea i
wanted to put out there because love's
house is so nice like they're obviously
very successful
yeah um so yeah actually i thought it
was a really great like very
well-rounded oh but then i also
how they um were filming like uh
through the windows like they had
everyone had their headphones in but
everyone's wearing mics so the audio is
good
everyone's on the phone and we can see
two people it's almost like they're
having a conversation
i preferred that to the zoom stuff no by
the way and the zoom stuff
was very high quality compared to what
we just watched on oc it was literally
like
android versus iphone 12 right but it
really shows like the different
production companies
and their creativity and their routing
covet filming
100 i just want to give a shout out to
craig's i thought he did such a good job
on hsn which is so cute and i just once
again like my disdain for patricia knows
no bounds like she was being so [ __ ]
rude
and condescending about like for craig
this is a major accomplishment
for anyone this is a major cause like
she was just like comparing it to her
like get out of here who even knew you
had a line of plates
no and like a chinchilla shawls but she
was on watchtrap and five afterwards and
she did kind of backtrack on it being
like
oh i have his pillows in my garden like
she
she's i just i don't ride for patricia
like at
all conceptually i think having you know
this woman on the show
just literally makes no sense and she's
always stirring the pot
on like the wrong side yeah i really
feel like so much of what southern charm
was for so many years was just like
the the men like this boys club and they
were just like so
unfair to the women and i feel like
patricia
has like allowed so many of those guys
to get away with that behavior yeah
you know yeah so the other part of the
episode that i thought was really
interesting was this love triangle
between pringle austin and madison
and for so long like i really rode for
austin and madison like i believed in
their love but
quarantine it really does change people
like you put everything in perspective
and it's like
madison spent quarantine like spending
quality time with her kid like
homeschooling him like
trying to you know keep her business
afloat whereas like austin's running
around town getting drunk which
you know what that's i'm not judging
like do you but it's like these two
people are not meant to be in a
relationship like they're just really
not on the same wavelength
yeah and it's sad because i was a stan
and
now that john pringle's in the picture
i'm just like i'm ready to let austin go
and it's like it really feels like
madison and austin like love each other
like i'm sure when they're together
having dinner like they're having the
best time you know
they enjoy each other's personalities
and and company
but it is a bummer that their lifestyles
are just not compatible
yeah and i feel like they've tried to
ignore that for two years and now
in covid it's not ignorable yeah um
i'm still on the fence about pringle oh
my god no i
he just like showed up and so we're
supposed to like him but he has to like
he's got to work a little harder he's
funny he's cute
and he loved like he loved madison from
like i just like someone who like knows
what they want he's like catherine liked
him i remember he made out with
catherine he was like not interested
he saw madison and he's not stopped
trying to pursue his instead it's like
that is a mature man like i just love
him he has around a date he has two kids
his kids are
so cute and he was like being so cute
making them sausage with egg and cheese
like they're so cute they're so that
the younger one is so cute like i just
that is the type of guy after watching
madison be in this like silly
relationship for two years
this is the type of guy she should be
with yeah i'm just not getting the vibe
that she likes him like at all i know
but i do like the idea like then like
hunter could join their bunk
yeah they could just be it would be a
merging of the bunks the cutest campers
it'd be so stinking cute so stinking
cute so
i'm actually really enjoying southern
charm yeah i think of all like and it
really is like
not fun to like go back in these tv
shows
to march like it's so depressing but
southern charm i found to be the least
depressing honestly well they skipped
through like
the worst months yeah that's true and
they were slow in oc
yeah like intentionally it's like no
southern charm did they skip to the
spring when things started to open
back up yeah we could do that you don't
need to see how you were like cooking
and
you know what we saw on your instagram
stories yeah totally
um so yeah i'm very much enjoying it and
that's all i have to say anything yes
really good stuff you have anything you
want to add before we wrap up i'm just
going to plug my book
girl with no job dot com slash book we
are six weeks away people
and i would sweet love if you could
pre-order my book it is available for
pre-order as an audiobook as an ebook
and of course a hardcover book you can
order online
from amazon barnes noble any indie
bookstores audible
if you just go to girlsonojob.com book
for us and canadians all the links are
there
for amazon canada indigo apple books
just please check it out growth on
job.com we're trying to get into the
airports i need
good pre-sale numbers so they'll put me
at the front of the airport hudson news
here i come
love it and if you love books you'll
love the redheads check out the redheads
book club
new episode just shopped it's really
good stuff and then follow us and you
know we're always giving book racks and
chatting with book lovers
i heard the reviews are in for the most
recent episode and they're
rave really you heard that i did i
didn't even go looking for that
information
it just truly slid across my desk whoa
we'd love to see it
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the best five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
already cast box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning to us and leave a
five-star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
we hope you have an amazing day amazing
weekend stay safe and we will see you on
monday for our final week of shows
before christmas break and hanukkah
break happy hanukkah everyone happy
hanukkah festival of lights goodbye
holy [ __ ]
you